c'est incroyable en fait on peut même
plus Ken tranquille aujourd'hui
[Rires]
qui existe sur terre et on peut même
plus le faire en de manière libérée
fait beaucoup rire il faut trop de
bruits sexuels
plusieurs habitants se sont plaints
amoureux devenu trop bruyant et trop
fréquent le problème c'est pas les
nuisances c'est que ça crée des des
problèmes dans les autres couples où les
femmes reprochent au mari genre elle a
de la chance
frustrations
à Los Angeles et il y avait un couple de
voisins il faisait exprès d'ouvrir les
fenêtres et voilà c'était de
l'exhibitionnisme et une fois ça fait
marrer deux fois trois fois et au bout
d'un moment on en peut plus ça devient
bien sûr
ce qu'il voulait peut-être que c'était
un message